[Music]
speaking of luck dude my luck's been
down
yeah
it's been down
tell us about it well i mean i told you
about the board right the board oh yeah
yeah yeah board yeah and the kid and the
kid
and that was a [ __ ] bummer yeah and
this is all happening i mean you hired
him inside your 12 million dollar home
to sort of simulate that whole thing so
kudos to him
no that really happened yeah
yeah in your 12 million dollar home
no
no and you're yeah that actually
happened yeah
um actually wait do you have that um
jack harlow
posts that i sent
did you did you send the board out for
repair
no not yet it's still i gotta dry it out
because it's like
broke through the
the glass yeah and into the foam a
little bit so if you get water in there
and then you glass it then it's like
waterlogged so you gotta dry it out and
then fix it
so yeah he posted this on his instagram
on uh what day was this march third
tuesday jack harlow just to start in
20th centuries white men can't jump
reboot off his first ever screen
audition right
okay so you know he's uh they're doing
the second batman and he's got the like
co-lead in that too
what no way yeah he's gonna be the
scarecrow
no way yeah there's no one
i mean but this is a major movie right
yeah woody harrelson was the guy who
played the last one
right
and this is his first okay so this is
so now i'll just rewind you've already
heard this story because i told you
um on sunday but
was it last week no the week before
whenever you put your arm in the cows
that was sunday it was a week and it was
no it was on friday oh okay so basically
i got
i haven't really i've sent like a couple
self tapes out some auditions for some
stuff
uh like once every month i'll get one
and all of a sudden i got a
call from my tv agent
he never he's never called me ever
before
and he was like yo man we got a big one
for you it's a producer session every
other role in the or for a pilot
every other role is already cast they
can't find someone for this this role
and they really like you it's a series
regular
and you're gonna do it on zoom tomorrow
it's four scenes and it's with the
producer
uh the writers and this is for like i
can't really say i don't think i can say
much about it probably not probably not
but it's for prime a primetime sitcom
right a multi-cam kind of classic like
sorry i'm just picturing you getting on
this zoom and they're like so do you
like anal
and you're like
jonathan
jonathan and then johnny sins walks in
jonathan jonathan sims nice to meet you
meet
jonathan
[Laughter]
then he pulls out his [ __ ] job wow
johnny big fan sorry is it jonathan
jonathan sins big fan you can call me
johnny but you can call him jonathan
jonathan
so anyway so he's like it's a big one
like they they really like you already
and i don't know i've never seen this
happen before but this is
straight to a producer session that's
usually what happens after you do the
audition and then the callback
and then you have a producer session and
then if they like you after that then
they test you with the network and once
you're at that point it means that it's
between you and like two other people
maybe yeah and you you negotiate the
deal and everything gets done so that if
they decide to go with you you can shoot
right away
right
so uh and this is like there's a i can't
i don't think i can say who but there's
a big ass comedian
very famous guy on the call who
who i'd be like acting with
so i did the auditions and i do the
first
two i pop on the casting director it was
like it's everyone like the writer
director the person i was just talking
about
jonathan sins
and uh the casting director is like cool
we're just gonna do the first two scenes
just you and me and i was like great so
everyone turns off the camera and i do
the scenes with him
and uh
you know
it's kind of like a flirty scene so a
little bit you know a little sexy sounds
a little weird over zoom doing that with
a man yeah who's like 50.
you know but i mean
oh god you're tearing my little [ __ ] up
yeah yeah
no it's it would be sorry
it would be you would be playing the guy
so i'd be like
oh i love your sweet huge boobs
and the cast and rex is like thank you
oh yeah oh you're the casting director
well i mean if it's jonathan sins and
you
oh man i love tearing up your sweet
[ __ ]
i'm not even gonna play that
[Laughter]
um okay we could go
jacob we're sad to say that
we're gonna have to anally probe you
oh no
oh no
we're sad to say that we're going to
have to sack tap you right now no don't
i would hate that dr sims enters the
room
dr jonathan
all right so you okay so i did the first
two scenes with this guy and everyone
turns their cameras back around like
back on and they're all like oh that was
really great okay now we're gonna do it
with the comedian and you know the other
person the other like
lead and so i was like okay cool so
everyone shuts off their cameras and i
do the two scenes and they're like
everyone same thing turns their cameras
back on they go that was really great
and they're all kind of giggling and i
was like thank you and they're like cool
the whole thing lasted like a minute
and so i'm like [ __ ] my pants right
because i like
i don't know i was just like you prepare
four scenes and you're just memorizing
it for like hours and then you go on the
whole thing takes a minute yeah and just
spy like goes by like this and you're
like i don't even know if i did a good
job or i blacked out i have no idea what
happens so i go inside to tell kelsey
and
the agent my agent calls me and he's
like they really liked you they want you
to do the other two scenes so you got to
go back on right now so i was like [ __ ]
okay so i get back on and do the
remaining two scenes
with the leads and same thing they all
turn their [ __ ] back on they're all like
oh my god that was really good and i was
like oh [ __ ] yeah thank you
turned to the camera off and or turned
the zoom off and i was like holy [ __ ]
that was surreal to go from not having
this to all of a sudden like
performing in front of these people and
like thinking that i was doing a good
job and so then he calls me like
10 minutes later my agent is like they
want to test you with the network
it's between you you and one other guy
and uh you you don't have to perform
again they're gonna they they recorded
what i did they're gonna take the
recording and just show the execs of
this major tv network and it's either
between you and this other guy so we got
to negotiate the deal right now so like
the next day my lawyer calls me he's
like it's a six-year deal
six years here's how much you're gonna
get paid if the pilot goes to series and
all this [ __ ] so i'm like in my head i'm
like planning my life as a as a
multi-cam actor you know i'm like well
cool
six years you know
like big bang theory type [ __ ] yeah
i was like let's go i could do that yeah
[ __ ] youtube you know yeah
[ __ ] it
get it out yeah
[ __ ] it just hit punch lines yeah you
know it's a little bit
of a dated format but i was like i could
sing my teeth into this you know i was
coming to terms with that it'd be a fun
new challenge
six years that's not too long
yeah
right people go to the military for four
yeah exactly
and so i was like i mean i was just
really excited it was like
it just seemed like a cool
new thing that i get like a cool new
challenge you know that was like what we
were talking about last
last week yeah it's like in the bonus
episode bonus episode sorry
yeah of course
um
it's like
youtube has felt like maybe it's kind of
run a court run its course a little bit
so it'd be fun to like sink our teeth
into something new and yeah
and uh and then
i don't hear back the next day because
they're still negotiating and then the
next day
agent calls me he's like so i got bad
news and i was like [ __ ]
and he was like i was like they picked
the other [ __ ] didn't they that [ __ ]
he's like no actually they decided to go
with neither of you
they're starting from scratch i was like
wow we were that bad they're like we're
actually gonna go with jack harlow yeah
no no so then i'm [ __ ] bummed right
i'm like my new board is [ __ ] broken
this
you know this this new six year journey
i was about to go on has come to an
abrupt end nil and then i opened up
instagram and jack harlow had posted
this about his first ever audition yeah
he gets cast in the lead how the [ __ ]
you bro
yeah god damn it yeah
well you know what
what you want some filet mignon
yeah cause that's on jack nice nice
yeah
no i'm no hate to him he's probably he's
probably a [ __ ] good actor that's the
thing the the thing that i'm
upset about is that i suck
that's what i'm upset about
he probably crushed it he probably
deserves the [ __ ] out of that role i
don't deserve that role that's why i was
upset
you know yeah they wanted to go with
someone that was more multicam
more multi-camera traditionally are they
calling your side profile [ __ ] up
is that what it was is that what they're
saying
oh camera d would look
horrible
on his round head
yeah
yeah dude
i come on set and the it's like you know
i'm just picturing like friends or
something like a classic like studio
show with a live audience yeah
i come on stage and everyone that's in
the front is like
everyone from the side
yeah damn
who the [ __ ] is this guy they don't even
boo they're just whispering amongst each
other yeah oh my god
his three-quarter profile is horrible
yeah they picked this guy
so gross
yeah
i'm not confident in this reboot
it's not to say that
this is nothing against jack it's just
you know we've been stuck in
reboot hell
you know for so goddamn long
we got no original ideas now because
hollywood's like oh [ __ ] it just break
out that property from 20 years ago yeah
it's good yeah even with music it's so
much of that now
every 90s song is getting repurposed
into some [ __ ]
there's a song
it's called like 5 500 degrees or
something
um it's like a collab project like song
with like
a bunch of rappers like the south and
stuff like estg and
42
or whatever
and they just took like juveniles like
400 degrees and then just it's them
rapping on it
and then
uh
[Music]
i for i forgot what but basically
pop punk
yeah pop punk and just everything i'm
like damn all right like our culture is
like dead dead yeah like we got nothing
yeah we have zero yeah
there's nothing left
this [ __ ] should just burn up we should
just reset the whole earth because we
got nothing yeah
like
and i think what's funny is
they're gonna reboot this and be like
it's like something from the 90s yeah
and then everyone's in there like
cosplaying as 90s people like doesn't
that depress the [ __ ] out of everyone
not really because people did that with
the 80s and the 70s it's just now it's
happening to us because the 90s is the
new 80s and 70s and 60s yeah that's fair
but so we're to us it's like this isn't
old like what do you mean i remember the
90s
yeah but i'm trying to think of like
when
like culturally when we were like yo
let's take that 80s thing and do it
again
like um
we wouldn't know because we're not from
that era yeah probably a lot of [ __ ]
yeah probably yeah
this is fair
but
no i feel like the 90s and the 2000s
yielded a lot of new things
they didn't have the transformer series
yeah it did because like
they had the transformers cartoon but
they didn't have like the michael bay
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and then
now now there's no
level like there's no upgrade level no
that no we maxed that one no there is vr
yeah but maybe
the metaverse